[Music]
I like to ask tough questions so here's
one can money buy you class I'm known
for my inspirational quotes but what you
may not know is they're also known as
plagiarism the anchors of The Today Show
get a real housewives makeover you know
you get a kick out of it well Kinda Yeah
yeah leave it to us we know the
housewives on Friday Savannah Guthrie
Jenna Bush Hager Craig Melvin Dylan
Dreyer Chanel Jones Willie Geist
albroker and Hoda copy brought the LOLs
creating their own Housewives taglines
in honor of bravocon which kicks off
this weekend in NYC are you ready for
the weekend Andy I think so I think so
I'm excited this is a culmination of a
long time you know what I always say
don't judge a bush by its cover
as a journalist I
use my forecast is always sunny across
me and I'll be waiting outside your
window
as fans of Real Housewives know the top
of each episode includes a montage of
each housewife with a quippy one-liner
representing their Larger than Life
personalities
I'm passionate about dogs just not crazy
about [ __ ] why be so nasty and so
rude when I can be so Fierce and so
successful I'm an acquired taste you
don't like me acquire some taste I used
to flip tables
now I'm turning them and when Real
Housewives executive producer Andy Cohen
stopped by the morning show he gave the
Today Show anchors his seal of approval
wearing Chanel is nice but being Chanel
is the ultimate luxury yeah what's my
Sunday morning secret a big bold mug
filled with a big bold Sauvignon blush
yes I usually predict Sunshine but I
always make it rain
okay are you into it I love it I just
want to say there was a less PG versions
Roker and Chanel and when Ed caught up
with Savannah and Hoda on Friday they
dished on those taglines now you guys
got to live out your Housewives fantasy
with a little uh tagline but I I hear
you were not so happy with yours no I
liked it but I did have one that was
like a little more um edgy edgy can you
share it no no she can't but it needed a
bleep you'd have to bleep it yeah but um
they thought it was safer if I did
something different so but who does the
what I've got a little sap yeah she's
got a little ass in there too yeah I saw
him this morning live when you showed
him we had fun doing that yeah the guys
were like what are we doing what is this
show we're like this is what you do yeah
yeah leave it to us we know the
housewife
[Music]